hey you know who's fired that I just uh
got hit to this year was Cash kid you
just got yourself just got hit bro he's
going right here for bird [__] for sure
earlier this year I I kind of like and
he came up here and freestyle and I was
just like no he could he been cold he
just happened
it's just one line to Raptor yeah he had
one of the biggest songs ever like
before I was I wasn't even rapping yet
my mom yeah oh my mama that was one of
the biggest songs that ever come out the
city he was one of the first people out
of the city 20 million views like that
man yeah
uh so you're gonna put out an album one
yeah like I'm putting together something
for the people what you calling it it's
eight count like you know who was
producing it with you yeah [__] me I
said who executive you ain't got an
executive producers you're just gonna
pick everything yeah
The Soul Man give them something to feed
off of you know yeah from these guys and
a few other guys you know hey why what
you know it's crazy because I I didn't
know that uh you and boldie were related
as well because of Bojack because like
sonically you guys are so kind of
different yeah he rap He rapping a lot
of left Pockets like he's doing he's
specifically a left-handed rapper I
loved it I like that he was just yes out
of town on tour it's his birthday it's
his birthday
it's his birthday happy birthday because
he just had he just had an accident and
he'd bounce back from the accident
against like his neck a little stiff but
he back walking working like Bojack one
of the coldest [__]
putting it like the cadences and the
[__] he say and he a [__] like that for
sure say some [__] I had to listen to
what the [__] you said a couple times
and be like I don't know what that is so
I'm gonna google it you feel me he like
narrate the streets 227 drugs man he
narrate that [__] him and Alchemist got
that [__] chemistry great ass
chemistry God his fire so good man so
good hey what is the status with uh
obviously miles Bridges was on your guys
is he still signed y'all don't nobody
leave this squad unless you just say I
ain't big Squad okay if you hear me was
he doing all right he's great he got a
contract uh we talked to him if not
daily weekly if I don't talk to him he
talked to him if he don't talk to him
rather talk to him like that's real
family yeah you know what I'm saying
like so he's doing shout out to him
being happy though that's all I'm about
to say like we care about that [__] it's
happiness he was going real trenched
babies man he was crazy
like in a month in a minute for a minute
like he was in a slump like and he
wouldn't let nobody know but you could
tell him I can imagine he's irritated by
itself
you gotta understand like you right
there from I could only imagine how I
feel to be right there [__] days away
from the biggest payday of your career
or your life insane and some [__]
happened like how it happened bro and
you just you know so like the prayers
was up for him at all times and we great
we glad he about it there bro that's
important like he back playing
basketball you feel me like he been
doing music or keep doing music and
because he's a [__] good rapper he's
yeah he's dope but he a great basketball
player for sure and I feel like he just
was getting in his in his bag where
people were like oh he been in the gym
every day and I think feel like he gonna
come back better
like he's about to have a great season a
career season like they need it and the
[__] that he was about to get they're
gonna have to pay him like y'all gonna
have to stuff all that other [__] in the
trunk it is what it is man he got
through it [__] Rehabilitation all that
type of [__] yeah and he's gonna play
great like he already was playing great
and he is everything all his averages go
up every year like it's a thing I do
with him before the season and I did it
down there every season instead of like
obviously couldn't do it last year but I
see my long-ass text message about how
much [__] I want him to do [__] and he
suddenly responding every time like I
got them [__] screenshot of him you
feel me and he do it the [__] averages
grow up every season and I think from
his career ass from that last season he
about to he about to do it again about
to go up again I remember one day he
told me like I think we've seen him
DeMar DeRozan did this [__] too he told
us he's playing the business like I'm
about to go for 30. and this is about
half time for 30. and he only had about
10. wow what did Mary tell you like he
wouldn't change his Kobe's
by the end of the third for sure yo I
felt for you and I really was rooting
for you
this last lottery
man that should hurt my feelings hey I
really ain't want to talk to [__]
because I know the lottery before about
this I think you and I had spoke right
before the lottery before when you guys
got Ivy but uh damn dude I still it
feels like it feels like y'all should
have had women Yana no we spoke we for
sure we're supposed to have K and wimby
but in the same token [__] it like I'm
I'm I'm cool with with us getting twin
and I feel like us getting twins gonna
turn into some [__] that I didn't that I
didn't even know or expect to come about
him so with him Ivy during I like beef
stew huh who's twin uh I started
Thompson oh okay okay yeah we got it we
gotta start right oh yeah one of the two
twins yeah yeah sorry amen yeah we got
we got a Tsar we still got Jalen during
like I feel like he gonna get better and
Jalen Darren just grew like two inches
yeah
he got to show me something him and
Marvin back like bro wise man gonna be
that way yeah
undoubtedly without him being can't hurt
he's a a basket rim protector I forgot
you guys also have the bags though here
run protector though oh you guys so you
think so this this one this I asked you
about ready about James Wiseman do you
think it was simply touches
with that he left like no I'm talking
about no not why he left I'm saying like
is that why he didn't flourish out there
because he didn't get enough time to
hoop he was injured from himself I was
saying he was healthy when they traded
him though you gotta think how I'm gonna
play James Wiseman I'm coming off a
championship season yeah it's insane why
would I change the lineup it's no room
there's no room for nobody to grow in
Golden State Jordan pool just was like a
flower rose growing from concrete like
and he grew and then they got yeah it's
like it's no room they don't even have
the the pay like that the salary did
he's stupid hey if you say if James
Wiseman had a big season how is they
gonna pay him
but I'm saying that's the only question
I have like pertaining to him coming
from that weight because a [__]
that said she like his niece still trash
like [__] like that you feel me like
more so
Marvin Bagley got a whole lot to prove
to me then watch me because I get I get
wise men to leeway and say like [__]
all right you was hurt a lot you feel me
badly badly you have done had an
attitude in Sacramento like you you
literally wasn't playing because you had
attitude my dad was saying videos of you
in the actual NBA game [__] telling
your coach no I ain't getting in when he
trying to sub you in but it'd be a lot
of I feel like politics it's like a lot
when it comes to confidence and and
um motivation I don't think a lot of
people be motivated to hoop for us
hey man y'all got Monty now the most the
richest coach in the NBA
I feel like coach I feel like he can
motivate them he will build the culture
yeah he'll build a culture a lot of
times just like this we got we have I'm
gonna do we still got Army
yeah we got we had homie one day homie
to play good the next day we come we
don't got me well we're here look we're
just playing
well he's playing behind me right hey
that's my my man Josh she works with Jay
Crowder so he will know okay Tommy was
playing good right he played good one
game right right the next game we come
to I'm sitting on the floor he's like
yeah I'm not playing this game I don't
know what reason but he's not on the
lineup for the game he told me he wanted
it so it's just like right that's not
motivation to keep playing good if I I'm
playing goodness
that's some [__] like I know I know he
told me I will if you hear me Casey had
to come to the moon and he don't play
with no more so [__] said he told me
out his mouth [__] didn't really
want to pray for Casey because he's a
military coach like he type of [__] had
the [__] making their beds up in the
hotel oh yeah like an old school coach
for sure and he probably was like one of
the only [__] who was Pro Killian okay
seeing Hayes here yeah
Kelly had been playing straight
what opportunity this season is the most
is the the best
how can I put it in nice words this
season this last year was the only time
that I wasn't just full-on ranting about
killing Hayes on Twitter he was straight
he was he played decent he played like a
solid he went from literally but like
but all I'm like but brother when I was
ranting about him like every day on
Twitter guys I'm gonna I'm gonna run off
and pissed when I was ranting about that
[__] every day on Twitter he literally
was the most inefficient [__] in the
league like it was a stat on it yeah but
it's a difference of playing in
Australia where I think he's from
implant in
um and with everybody that could jump
run shoot slam dunk on you block your
shot from the top of the backboard it's
different like no it is now tell me this
they play I know you wouldn't have did
it and you probably don't remember that
Dragon cause I badly remember but [__]
who you you would you think you would
have got drafted would you have did he
come in
or call Anthony right we could have had
Cole Anthony I told y'all
I wouldn't have even got certain I'm not
gonna even say the name because I I [__]
with buddy but I would have took
[__] Jalen um sucks I told you
all that and then Kelly age draft I
would have took Jalen Subs
no no no sex was in that draft it was
Jalen sucks he can't we got a little no
Sexes after no we got Killian Hayes the
next year after we got
um
Whatchamacallit no kill me Killian was
here before okay
thank you thank you but I think Cole
Anthony came in that same draft no he
got drafted no Cole Anthony got drafted
no no the same here is Killian because
the year before we got the number one
draft pick all right so I'm gonna tell
you so the draft that Killian was in the
number one pick was was Ant-Man
so we could have had
OB topping
Halliburton wouldn't have been good I
would have got Halliburton but cold
Anthony nobody knows I'm just saying
instead of Killian Hayes call Anthony
Tyrese Maxie Kelly
yeah
I would have got Tyrese for sure
and that's why he was the best one in
that draft bro nothing beats
bro Maxie been nice since Texas in high
school like these be the [__] a [__]
like me and brother been paying
attention to for a while and know what
they about right I was a maxi fan bro
like staying at Kentucky bro what that's
what I'm trying to tell you like [__] I
DM that [__] when he still was in high
school bro like I've been like I've been
reaching out to all these [__] you're
trying to tell like bro you cold you're
gonna be nice yeah bro my mama bro so
like when I see him in the draft and
then we pick Kelly and Hayes over all
these [__] that I've been watching
since high school did not know is gonna
come and do they Thug fizzle but this
it's a lot of stuff going to that [__]
pay all that [__] I don't know what our
cap at though I don't know how much we
got I think we got a lot of money coming
into next season yeah I don't feel like
we can't we ain't have enough to pay
these people bro
um talking about the pigs that we wanted
to pick like once they would have got
good what
I understand so you'd be looking at [__]
from SAS that I don't know
like yeah a lot of guys want to play in
Detroit a lot of people say that like
that's not a lot of people say I don't
want to go there
and then who am I to pick somebody that
don't want to play
yo why would I pick you if you don't
want a beer
I mean [__] that you're good enough a
lot of people say that like I absolutely
you don't know how many people said I
absolutely don't want to go to that's
what happened with Josh Jackson he told
the Celtics he wouldn't play for them so
then he fell to us and you know shout
out to Josh good guy but Jesus that
didn't end well for us yeah
no great guy he's my baby yeah no we
know Josh Jackson used to be he actually
pulled up to the club in Phoenix I was
DJing you were performing and Josh came
through that's my little brother man
when I we used to walk in the gym
Josh was like
LeBron James to Detroit bro Josh is so
good like if you watch him in College
Kansas come on you had to see him at
high school like for sure they shut gyms
down like